why do I have to follow those rules who
said there's only one way to do
something so what if no one has done
this before good morning believe nation
today's messages always be questioning
and I'm going to share with you an
inspiring clip from Aaron Schwartz feel
very strongly that it's not enough to
just live in the world as it is to just
kind of take what you're given and you
know follow the things that adults told
you to do and that you know your parents
told you to do and that society tells
you to do I think you should always be
questioning you know I take this very
scientific attitude that everything
you've learned is just provisional that
you know it's always open to recantation
or refutation or questioning and I think
the same applies to society and I you
know felt growing up you know I slowly
have this process of realizing that all
the things around me that people had
told me were just the natural way things
were the way things always would be
weren't natural at all they were things
that could be changed and they were
things that more importantly were wrong
and should change and once I realized
that there was really kind of note going
back I couldn't fool myself into saying
oh I'm just going to go work for
business and ignore all that once I
realized that there were real serious
problems fundamental problems that I
could do something to address I didn't
see a way to to forget that I don't see
a way not to this is a really important
message for entrepreneurs because as
business owners that's how we create our
livelihood we asked questions we
challenge the status quo we see
something that we want to change in the
world that we go out and we make that
change you have to see that the world
that you live in today was made by
people who are no smarter than you they
didn't like something so they change it
and they created new rules that's what
you have to do as well as an
entrepreneur if you're not happy with
something if you're frustrated with
something if you're looking at something
in the world that you don't like don't
just sit there and complain about it
don't gripe don't post something on
Twitter or Facebook about how angry you
are be the change start making something
happen always be questioning and that's
how you can build a fantastic business
so my question the day for you today is
what are you questioning what's the
change you want to make in the world
leave it in the car
below i'm going to join the discussion
and i look forward to hearing what you
have to say thank you so much for
watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and i'll see you again
tomorrow for another shot events press 0